- I'm starting to feel it now.
- Oh my God.
- Fire!
(coughing)
You're shaking!
- I need some milk.
I need some milk!
- [Girl] No!
(playful music)
- Hi there!
I'm Aria, and I love to eat.
Although not quite as much
as the mukbang performers
who can be regularly seen
eating large quantities of food
in front of thousands
upon thousands online.
This phenomenon was born in Korea
and I'm thinking, what
better way to learn about
the art of the Mukbang, than
by performing one myself?
Goddamn, it's hot.
Blowing up since 2008, mukbangs
feature broadcast jockeys,
or BJs, who stream
themselves as they consume
large portions of food while
interacting with viewers
that according to one theory,
eat vicariously through them,
and to get the proper experience,
I'm meeting with Hyunee,
one of Youtube's most
popular mukbang stars.
- Let's dig in 'cause I'm so hungry!
- Mukbang literally means eating show,
but to me, it's being a
friend to my Hyunee-bees
who are my subscribers.
So this is my kitchen where I normally
cook all my food for my mukbangs.
- What would you say is the craziest thing
you've cooked yourself?
- The craziest thing is
mozzarella corn dogs.
- Did you eat all of them?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Some people who come to my channel say,
"Her intro is so cringy!"
but I love that I can be more silly
and just be myself when I build mukbangs.
I think about all these ideas
and then I start writing
it on the whiteboard.
- So you basically eat food
from all around the world.
- My dad always introduced
me to different types of food
and that's what my
Hyunee-bees love about me
because I try different types of food.
When I was around six or seven years old,
my dad fainted and when
we went to the hospital
the doctor said he only
had six months to live,
but he actually fought for 14 years.
Through mukbangs, I tell my life story
and I get to remember my dad,
and get to share all the
food that I shared with him
with my Hyunee-bees.
So right here is, ta-da!
My mukbang room!
- [Aria] This is where the magic happens.
- [Hyunee] Yeah, exactly.
- I gotta ask.
Is there a sexual element
to this for some viewers?
- I think so.
A very few percentage, but I think mostly,
the slurping sound makes
you wanna eat the food
so it's not too much
of the sexual content.
I think people watch mukbangs
because they wanna make new friends.
That's one reason why I
started my mukbang channel.
Mukbang isn't all about filming
and eating in front of the camera.
It's more about helping others
with depression, anxiety,
and being their companion.
- [Aria] Having heard more
about Hyunee's process,
I'm now ready to tackle
the mukbang challenge
she has arranged for me.
- The challenge is I'm gonna
try to eat five noodles
and you're gonna try to eat five noodles
and see who eats it faster.
A lot of people have actually tried this.
I'm surprised that you haven't.
- Evan, no!
I'm actually worried about your insides.
- You're really gonna get a major BTS.
- BTS?
- Booty Tingling Sensation?
- You know what?
I actually have a little
extra surprise for you.
- What?
- I say we grate ourselves
some Trinidad Scorpion Peppers on time.
- You know what, I actually
have a surprise for you.
(playful music)
I have the world's hottest chocolate.
(laughing)
- Oh.
We do the challenge, we grate
a little bit of this on top,
and then--
- And then we could
try this after.
Dessert.
- Dessert.
Okay.
- We're gonna boil two eggs.
One for me, one for you.
It helps coat your stomach
before you eat anything spicy.
So in Korea, we crack each other's eggs.
Can I show you?
Oh my gosh!
- That egg was definitely
not cooked all the way.
- [Hyunee] I'm so sorry!
(upbeat music)
- And after preparing a
dish that could easily feed,
and possibly kill, a family of eight,
the stage is set for us to begin.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, Hyunee-bees
it's your girl, Hyunee,
and this is.
- [Aria] Aria!
- So let's dig in 'cause I'm so hungry!
(clapping)
- Three, two, one.
(playful music)
I was starting okay,
but then the heat started
really building up in my mouth.
How are you feeling?
(mumbling)
You okay?
I definitely bit into some of that pepper
'cause I felt some of the flakes,
and it just snowballed.
- You're crying!
My tongue's burning now.
- My lips are really feeling it.
I was at the point where I
couldn't even put my mouth
'cause my lips were on fire.
- You're shaking!
- I need some milk!
I need some milk!
- No!
Already?
- I'm not gonna drink it yet.
I grab Devy and Christian.
Christian, get in here.
They jumped in.
How is it?
So you usually talk about life, right?
(Hyunee mumbling)
Cool.
I was like, you know, screw it.
I'm just gonna wolf down as much as I can.
- Whoa.
- [Christian] There we go.
- And that may have been
(alarm ringing)
a very foolish choice.
- Oh my God!
- Because then right after that,
out came the chocolate chili.
I'd like to dedicate this to
all the mukbangers out there.
Let's stay mukbanging.
And it all went downhill from there.
Oh no, I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling it.
- I feel it now.
- It's on my tongue.
I need the milk.
(coughing)
Than you everyone for
watching this Buzzfeed video
about mukbang.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'll see you guys in my next video.
Bye!
Oh, I feel it.
(Aria yelling)
My throat!
- [Devy] Oh God, Aria.
- Why did we do this?
- I think if I had to
experience a mukbang,
that was the way to do it, all in.
You have any final thoughts about mukbang
you'd like to share?
- Mukbang isn't all about
eating in front of the camera,
it's having fun and meeting new friends.
That was one of the craziest
most fun experience of my life
and I'm so happy that mukbang
can bring people together.
I just wanna keep doing it
and I wanna thank all of my Hyunee-bees
for supporting me and loving me.
I love you guys!
- I would gladly do a mukbang again.
Maybe just not this dish, you know?
Maybe just some nice McDonald's.
Hit that Dollar Menu up.
McChicken, the McChicken
never does this to you.
The McChicken never does this to you.
(playful orchestral music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
Subscribe here.
- Subscribe here.
That was my part.